did you realize serving drugs what is a
caffeine i don't know i just said give
me something
are we live or no do we get money from
paul are we live or no
we're live okay adam we're officially
live here we go
and and i think it's important before we
get started with the 45th episode with
tom ellsworth being in town here with us
he's out here with us i think we have to
tell everybody what we saw this morning
when we
when we pulled in it's crazy so we pull
in no joke
okay we pull in this morning parking lot
parking lot
exactly and we see paul e running routes
he's just running drones
in the morning 7 30. our camera guy paul
i wish you could see his face paul os
garcia goes running routes
he's into what song six one two forty
six one two forty played for chaplain
university yeah right big dude
what song was he working out what was it
keith's
what lsg my body all over
your body who works out to
lsg and keith sweat only our buddy paul
everybody give a shout out to paulie
paul you're just something else buddy
tupac tupac right okay anyways it's it
was a sexy workout it's a sexy workout
he's trying to speak in a sexy
let's give an intro to the oh thank you
i went there i went there
yes sexy tom in boca in the house
that's right and by the way you grew up
here you grew up in boca yeah my dad's
job
just down here in the last two years of
high school i was i was a boca guy
tom your dad was a what rocket scientist
literally he was a rocket scientist yeah
he was a mathematician guy
washington state university small school
middle of nowhere and
you know mathematics genius was a rocket
scientist in ireland
by the way that's like literally his dad
was a rocket scientist yeah it's like
i'm no rocket scientist but no i
actually am
you guys this explains so much but you
know it's really funny you look back at
the pictures there
and here is him with his short sleeve
white shirts
little skinny black ties and had slide
rules you know
and there would be like 30 or 40 of them
you would see this team
and i'm like wow what'd you do he says
we were putting men into orbit
and we were building we went about
missiles and rockets and bombs we were
putting men into orbit we wanted to beat
the russians
so they had vision mission all that now
there's probably
five guys from mit with big computers
back then it was 40 guys and everything
that was we were proud of it let me
so by the way this morning we're having
breakfast and tom what is tom doing tom
takes the moment
it takes a moment to teach the kids
about the difference between mahi mahi
el dorado and san diego and dolphin
but not the kind of dolphin you think it
is so tom just teaching right and the
kids are like enamored by tom's teaching
he's showing all these pictures
was your dad also somebody that would
always teach you like was he like you
like would you like him
yeah what you know what we didn't have a
lot growing up i mean we were just
middle class and he was he was always
teaching talking about you said you guys
grew up in a six million dollar home in
boca
raton no no no no no this is this is
broken in the 80s and we were like out
west by before 41. yeah i can only
imagine being able to see was your dad a
rocket scientist
that was back then that was the border
there was boca west then 441 and then
animals and swamp i'm just i'm still
revisiting this this rocket scientist
how many you know i mean how many times
i've said look i'm no rocket scientist
question
if you're watching this who has a
relative that is
or was a rocket scientist if you're
watching this comment i'm actually
curious to know how big the community
of rocket science did you have anybody
that was a rocket scientist i figured if
anybody would have had a rocket
scientist would be kai
paulie any rocket scientist and a family
no my dad's a electrical engineer but
not
okay i mean your dad's a pretty legit
guy chris shout out to your dad chris
sam sam anybody anybody was a rocket
scientist in your family
nobody okay let's see if anybody we had
here that was a rocket scientist
definitely nobody in the our family was
a rocket scientist i bet you'd find a
lot of people from southern california
that's where the space program was all
right
all those guys there's probably a lot of
people middle age that had moms and dads
that worked in that industry l.a so i
have i have a friend
that was probably one um
one one uh uh uh hallucigen away from
being a rocket scientist he was he was
he was that
uh legit of a guy that could have gone
there he was a mathematician you know
what i'm talking about what do you mean
one hallucination one
one like he should have done one more
pyramid he did
one too many well he was a genius when
he came down there was a couple guys in
our school that were good in math he was
one of them
and uh he could have been a rocket
scientist but he sells kebab today
is what he sells he's a kabob salad he's
in the kebab business is what he's doing
the kebab business is booming
anyways you told me you are very excited
about today's topics
any reason why you're very excited about
today's topic because i noticed
that you came in pretty amped up i don't
know if it's a caffeine pill i don't
know what's going on but i don't know if
it's just the biz doctor
you didn't take the pill from the guy in
the lobby yeah yeah that guy that guy
i'm amped up
there was a guy looking like with a man
purse his name was zach
and he said who let the dogs out and he
offered him a couple pills i don't know
if it was roofies or
coffee you know roofies i don't say no
you ever seen that argument roofie you
won't be saying no have you ever seen
the documentary hangover you ever seen
the documentary and go over the
documentary
yeah i i saw the documentary um
it starts in las vegas no no it starts
in las vegas there's a tiger in the
bathroom these guys wake up you know so
it's like uh
yeah that one yeah i don't know why they
call it roofies they should call it
flores because you always end up on the
floor
who made you laugh the most in hangover
well obviously zach alpinakis is
something else
is my son pedro
hangover look what he's doing
when they're having breakfast i remember
we watched the first one we're like this
is hilarious
you watch the second one with friends
you're like a little awkward you watch
the third one okay they just crossed the
line okay so third one is not one you're
going to watch with
your your friends and family it's a
little awkward but for by the way wolf
of wall street you know who i watch wolf
of wall street with the first time
with my dad okay at arclight in sherman
oaks we're sitting there my dad
is crap by the way the whole place is
jumping your dad is laughing my dad is
in
tears cracking up the entire time
in every scene i haven't heard my dad
laugh that loud that's like
wall street yeah your dad your dad
wasn't asking questions
he wasn't asking questions what is all
the sugar on her butt and what is he
doing
no no no no my that's my that's a
well-trained it's a g that's a
well-traveled man
okay so let's get right into it let's
get into the topics we got a lot of
exciting stuff
we're having some flurries okay uh by
the way here's what we're gonna do
if you're watching this if you're
watching this and you
have a question or you want us to cover
a topic kai
is following twitter hashtags if you go
on twitter and you put in
pbd podcast once again pbd podcast with
any questions you have or topics you
want us to cover
kai will be following that by the way my
handle is at patrickbetdavidso if you
tweet at patrickbetdavid or pbdpodcast
kai will let us know maybe some of the
tweets will even be shown on the screen
to see what the question is so cai you
follow that uh trend as we're going
through it but let's get right into it
we started 30 minutes a little earlier i
know we said 9 a.m
we did 8 30 because i got a 10 30
meeting today and i figured we'd start
30 minutes early
rather than doing a 90-minute show we
said let's do two hours she will start
30 minutes earlier
we're getting good feedback people like
this time yes so so let's get right into
it so we got topic spac versus ipo i
think it's important for people to
realize
what's going on with specs versus ipos i
think it's 20 what was the number 70
billion dollars we'll touch up on that
you got a lot of feedback
craziness yeah crazy numbers disney plus
just topped 100 million subscribers in
16 months
it took netflix 60 months to do it they
did it in 16 months
and wait till you hear what they're
projecting to do
which the number is absolutely
astronomical 37
americans in a recent survey said that
they made trades based on elon musk's
tweet
tweet americans cut credit card debt by
nearly 83 billion dollars during the
pandemic elon musk
spacex now owns about a third of all
active satellites in the sky
um uh next we have okay elon musk made
another 25 billion dollars yesterday in
24 hours what a rough day you know when
you make 25. he loses 25
he makes 25 just another day with elon
musk stories
hybrid working will become the norm how
much money you need to live comfortably
in every state in america it's
interesting to see
what is the most expensive state to live
in and most
cheapest cheapest state to live in we'll
cover those numbers
zoom's founder eric juan just
transferred 18 million shares six
billion dollars
and everybody's wondering why that is
tom's got some uh speculation on what
happened over there
uh u.s lawmakers one thing we've been
talking about for a while
introduce bill to clarify crypto
regulations
you do not want to see regulations and
crypto in the same same sentence
but we're headed in that direction we'll
see what's going to happen there when
there's a party the government's going
to regulate it that's right
democrats may just have laid the
groundwork for biden to cancel 50
dollars a student debt per person we'll
see what happened there russia slowed
down twitter's speed and
threatened a total block after the site
allegedly failed to delete
banned content russia's back at it again
can you imagine you're threatening a
company in the us from russia where you
have control over saying i swear to god
if you don't delete banned content
we're going to ruin your website imagine
the kind of power you have to be able to
do something like that
biden administration plans to buy
another 100 million 100 million extra
doses of jnj
covet vaccine uh the one shot
the one yeah one shot that's right the
one shot and then china is behind a new
huge cyber attack of microsoft and then
we got a few other things that's going
on
texas pink raider texas tech offers the
two-day-old
daughter of patrick mahomes a full-ride
scholarship to play soccer there
obviously we got to cover myers leonard
what he said while he was playing video
games and julian edelman responding to
him
and then uh cuomo you know a story came
out that he groped uh grow
under the shirt we may cover that i
don't know whether we're going to get
into that or not but we've got a lot of
stories here okay then our voyage
gronk is uh nft is right he's starting
an nft for himself yeah he's starting an
nft so why don't we go into the disney
story i said we start off with the
disney story first
so uh 100 million subscribers in 16
months
initially they projected to have 60 to
90 million subscribers by
they are way off three years
ahead of their projection they hit a
hundred million
and a company spokesperson said disney
expects to hit ready for this number
300 to 350 million subscribers by 2024
watch them miss that mark as well right
if they missed that mark
it took netflix 10 years to accumulate
100 million subscribers after launching
in 2007
whereas disney plus took less than a
year and a half and
in october disney plus pulled dumbo
peter pan and the aristocrats amongst
other films from kids profiles
because of racist stereotypes depicted
in these films let me get this straight
so dumbo peter pan and aristocrats
i actually like all of those movies but
they pulled it out
and uh the film's removal from kids
profiles comes amid a nationwide
campaign to slap disclaimers
on or outright banned old movies tv
programs and books deemed racist and
offensive anyways
two different topics in the same subject
here with disney
tom what are your thoughts with
listening against netflix uh disney plus
you know what i think this is
i think this is a leadership um
uh case study here and i'll tell you why
i think that the guy running disney plus
a guy named michael paul i met michael
paul when he was at
fox in los angeles california and i was
at go tv
michael paul's a very impressive guy was
an absolute leader he leaves
fox and gets recruited to go run video
for amazon
so let's follow the crew trajectory and
look at the leadership he's up at amazon
runs video and then he gets recruited to
disney i think it's in new york
to come run disney plus when i saw that
i felt
and it's michael paul p-a-u-l-l uh great
guy
double l what yeah double l uh it's the
paul family with the x-rail
and so i really was impressed by the guy
when we would talk there we would talk
about where's
go tv going to go where i think it
should go what's going on with fox and
we
a lot of times just connected with him
uh professionally we weren't next door
neighbors or anything but grabbed a
couple lunches with them
always always very sharp and i kind of
noticed you know what was going on
i think this is a leadership thing this
is not somebody that grew up in disney
with production film this is a guy that
cut his chops with a stop at amazon and
it doesn't surprise me
that he's driving it this way at all i
thought the blending was good i thought
the espn plus they put in there
and the way they put it all together
they recreated the cable company
boom and he's driving it and i'm not
surprised by this i'm not surprised
at all i'm a hulu subscriber from like
day one do you think they're going to
hit the 300 to 350 or you think they're
going to surpass it and a half a billion
i don't know it all depends on what you
know you've got canada you you the other
markets
it's it's the take rate in foreign
markets because
you've only got how many how many
hundred million homes in america and
three hundred and thirty three hundred
right 45 million yeah but it's it's
homes homes is different than
population right so right if you count
four to one
so we're dealing with only a hundred
million in u.s let's just say or 90
million in us you have to figure out a
way to expand internationally get a
number like that yeah that's that's
exactly right but what's happening in
the us
i think they're just sucking the error
out of the room youtube tv
didn't get going fast enough and you
know you had they had a head start they
had a lot of things going on
question for you can they go into china
can disney plus go into china
can you check to see if disney plus is
in china right now can they go into
china because
look kids watch disney from all parts of
the world so i'm curious enough that is
a market they're
considering that they're going to get
into that's going to give them a chunk
of that business right there
of 350. adam what's on your mind disney
made the
it's a small world after all famous
we've all been there we know it's a
small world we're all in connected world
what i gotta appreciate about the biz
dock is you're looking at the story
and you see some of these numbers and
we'll kind of get into it
but of course tom ellsworth knows the
guy michael paul
with two l's did he oh yeah i met him
back at a party and we were doing
a video conference like that kind of
insight is actually very impressive like
no one would know
but speaking of leadership like who if
we forget
you know we're thinking of these massive
companies but no one understands like oh
well there's a guy named reed hastings
and this is his philosophy and this is
correct the book that he wrote and this
is why netflix became that company
and like there's a story behind the
story and what you're essentially you're
saying is like yeah disney the name of
disney
is obviously a popular name and people
get it but no there's this dude named
michael paul
with two l's and here's the deal here's
where he came from
but let me let me kick it over to you
pat i've been pretty vocal about this
because we've covered you know when
quibby didn't you know
and i was like what the hell's quibby at
the time
you said something yesterday like the
big three um
hospitality in hospitality in uh
uh what was the big three that you said
in regarding uh you had airlines
and you had restaurants it's the ones
that got
hit heaviest by coach during the
pandemic you kind of sort of
gave it its own moniker the big three
what's the big three when it comes to
streaming obviously netflix is numero
uno right
but disney is right there it's coming up
on its heels so it seems
then you got amazon prime how many
players is there a big three is there
going to be a big five
top top otts in the world top ott
because you can only have so many how
many of these can you have like
when quippy failed i was like yeah
obviously because there's freaking
ten other things they're competing with
you got hulu who looks like sports
just put okay there you go oh hbo is one
as well that's right that's the one that
you got to be looking out for because
hbo
is competing in the marketplace and you
have so many things that i've never
heard of type in the us top ott
okay streaming platforms in the u.s
look at that do you see that wow
you know what kyle's doing over the
weekend guys learning better
ladies and gentlemen the fingers of
lightness that's that's uh
already a month old but we'll see what
that says so youtube is considered ott
for netflix so
youtube is in the mix amazon vimeo
but i think you have to look at those
things the multi-channel because the
youtube here is youtube red and a few
things
like that you know just access people
intentionally buying it
you know so everybody thought and by the
way i did a case study on
netflix remember i talked about that
netflix without that all the disney
programming
going off the air you're going to have
some challenges
netflix is holding its own and even
raised prices a buck
so it's netflix for designated
you have to look at it two sides the
live tv side hulu live tv is really good
and then netflix is the premium
programming going back to house of cards
and things that they built themselves
um although house of cards came out of
britain i got a question for you guys
here's a question for you what's more
impressive disney going from
zero to 100 million in 16 months or
netflix going from zero to 100 million
in 10 years
well i think you would argue that
netflix was the organic growth
entrepreneurially
on thank you adam reed hastings and his
leadership
and then disney kind of took their own
stuff
and then bought up the rest of the air
out of the room you know they bought
they bought the libraries
so that's there's your acquisition
strategy what's tougher though what's
tougher
what's more impressive i think it's i
think it's tougher what netflix did over
10 years
i think that's much tougher yeah i mean
disney had let's face it all the money
in the world they have a monopoly
yeah and they have content galore from
how many years
well yeah then they bought the stack
from fox they bought the they got the
marvel they got the star wars i mean so
they bought everything yeah
the how much credit here goes to iger
how much does iger get credit
for what he did during his 15 16 years
of doing what he did and
buying out star wars buying out fox
buying out every
how much does how much of the credit
goes to iger uh i like bob
um i don't agree with him on everything
that he says and does where he crosses
over in the politics
and and what not but i i think he
doesn't have to apologize that
that was the hand he was played i have
disney i've got money and i'm going to
go buy it i don't think you apologize
for that
his job was to grow and to deliver for
the shareholders and he did it
now is that as impressive as what reid
hastings did
no but i think in the chair that he
inherited with
the the hand he was dealt i think he did
a good job yeah i
i say reed hastings kudos to the guy for
building something that you have
you have nothing you have to create
content you have to go
get people to come and visit your you
have to get you know hey let's go
what do you got here netflix 204 million
prime 150 spotify 144.
i can't read the next one is it trescent
tencent 120.
and then it's uh what's the next one at
119.
okay and then you have disney at 95 yoku
had 90 million
uh can you make it bigger i actually
want to see who's next after that
because i want to know how many of these
we're using go
go a little bit more do one more layer
do one more okay that's good
so disney 95 yoku 90
apple music 68 music amazon 55 i don't
know who the next one is 57
e what does that say vo and then hulu 39
who was only at 39 million
arrows and then youtube premium 30
million serious 34 million disney
uh another one right there you got show
time
paramount hbo max is only 17 million i
thought for sure hbo would have been
bigger number than that
because a lot of stuff you're seeing
lately going straight to hbo max
but remember you take disney plus plus
the hulu plus the espn plus plus the
disney
yes yes no question about it well
this was essentially my point and this
is why i actually i i kind of
disagree with you guys on the netflix
thing yeah disney had
sort of a lead in the race but look at
how much competition is out there
like we can't even we don't even know
half these names we're talking about i
don't even know that one what's this
it's there's just so much competition so
yes it's disney yes it's a big
you know behemoth type of company but
you still have to compete in the
marketplace you still have to have a
good product you still need to have adam
what did you drink this morning i went
all over the map baby morning
what was in that pill can we check the
ingredients
okay all right here's the here's the
deal the first stock
that i've ever owned in my life was
disney my grandma bought me like
20 shares of disney when i was like born
yeah so i still have them
they're the only individuals yeah i
still have them
so i mean she probably bought them for
like a nickel back in uh
1980. and now they're worth you know a
decent amount of money is it a decent
amount of money yeah i don't know it's
like probably
30 grand yeah like pretty cool she
bought you 20 shares and it's worth 30
grand maybe not maybe
26 grand somebody i don't know i don't
know the exact number yeah it's pretty
cool right to do that
thanks grandma i mean guys long you know
buy and hold buy and hold hold
so point is i got a little soft spot for
disney so when i see disney kind of
doing all right
it's a small world yeah all right i'm
buying it let's go find
adam cinderella already i think that's
what i'm about honestly how many times
have you seen cinderella
be honest 50 60. recently
i'm talking last week just like the last
week probably 20 times
i saw cinderella i'm looking for that
slipper baby
you got two daughters i saw cinderella
like three times he opened for poison
right is that right
so anyway i'm just impressed with what's
going on disney back to you
oh my last point last point and then i'm
gonna turn over the biz doc
speaking of competition speaking that
all there's all these different
competitors out there
yeah you know you brought up the big
three we talk about
um you know you have uber and you have
lyft
you've got amazon you've got walmart in
the streaming world there's
a couple dozen names that you have to
compete with
so to be in the top three or even the
top five in that category is very
impressive
any final thoughts there tom before we
move on i gotta make one salute to reed
hastings and his management team
when he came out i look at who wanted
you dead
hbo wanted him dead he's putting movies
in the hands of consumers that's
hbo's realm showtime cinemax all those
they wanted him dead and yet he was
getting these
you know blockbuster remember
blockbuster video jim keys they wanted
him dead so you have to look at these
incumbents that were massive when he
came out there the number of people that
wanted
him to fail when they had less than
nothing
and here they are the dust is cleared
and a lot of those names i mentioned are
gone or demuted in their influence so
that's that's what i look at netflix
here's my final question to you pat
yeah how many of these streaming
services do you have in the
bet david household i couldn't even tell
you so we obviously don't know more than
five
we have disney we have netflix we have
uh
amazon prime yeah i think those are the
three that we that's it you have three i
think we have three okay how many
ask ask mario mario over there mario
owns
underground uh you know streaming
services mario owns
pretty much every single thing that you
can see on streaming seriously owns all
of them why is mars subscribe to all of
them why
i don't know mario is a content guy he's
an underground kind of guy he's an
underground content type of guy i think
i got like a
see assimilation i think so i got
eight streaming services hbo max well
apple tv
netflix amazon prime yeah uh stars
um what else kids sweats
[Music]
you talking about a guy that when the
movies were open paul how many movies
were watching every week at the movie
theater honestly
oh uh three minimum every week yeah no
matter what
in addition to all your ott i wasn't
streaming as much to be honest
paul when you watched do you get the
popcorn in an icy or you just go watch
the movie and you leave
uh i would rotate you will rotate
sometimes yes i would just go in many
times a week no matter what i mean do
they even make three movies every week
like
is there not anymore that's why i
haven't i've honestly seen probably one
a month now okay so we're starting to
get some questions here folks if you got
some questions i mean
i'm seeing already questions on the
podcast the uh
cool guy alert says let's talk about
dogecoin uh
some folks are talking about uh uh i'll
just go into the next question here
kevin
kevin thatcher if you want to go on the
twitter just to have it up to see it
and put it on the big screen so we can
see kevin thatcher shout out to kevin
real estate or crypto as long-term
investment i'm a real estate guy but i'm
thinking crypto tom
i'm gonna ask you here's a good question
do i invest in real estate
long-term investment or do i do crypto
for a long-term investment both you guys
are money guys i'm curious to know what
you're going to say about this
i'm going to say real estate on the
conservative side so if you're younger
and you've got
time to make a recovery later in life
yeah you could take a bet on crypto and
see where it goes
but if you're over 40 i would probably
say
real estate because it's got permanent
scarcity and
more people come in the united states so
that would be my
headline what would you say age is a
factor
for sure but um i like to keep things
moving i like that
portability so i've been very vocal like
i'm not trying to just stay
in a house and just wait for the house
to appreciate and so i'm going in on
crypto versus real estate for sure so
long term you're saying
crypto over real estate yeah okay i
agree well you got to realize real
estate long term what is that what is it
done what's the number on really three
percent three percent yeah
it's a real estate good luck with that
house yeah but he's saying
conservatively
crypto conservatively this is the old
school thinking it's the new school
thinking i'm more of a crypto guy he's a
real estate guy that's fine
if i was 22 no student loans coming out
i would
be on crypto you would and you know and
i'd be
hanging with bitcoin because the i think
there's can you put his tweet up i'm
begging you put the tweet up like i've
been asking
texting and sending signals but tom are
you a a big real estate guy in general
forget about crypto just in general like
you buy your house you you have a
mortgage where are you at with just real
estate in general
real estate i like the mathematics of
rental property with the cost of housing
no no that's not what i asked because
everyone goes well i'd like to have a
rental property i mean just
literally having a mortgage buying a
house paying down your mortgage that
concept
uh no i'm really not i'm really not
you're not no and you're a numbers guy
why not
um well at the at the time i would have
bought and at the time
earlier you know we had five and seven
percent you know
mortgages maybe even higher than that
and and that was that was the good era
mm-hmm and so i i think that the
price of the mortgages is everything
well
price of mortgages are extremely low
right now right now right so it's a
different
different world right now you're saying
back when you bought yeah but now i'm
talking about
oh oh yeah you know the government wants
to give me two percent money
you'll take it i'll take it all day long
look two percent money and three percent
appreciation you're 50
ahead of the government so it doesn't
sound like big numbers but you're ahead
okay but it's
a conservative plan you're crypto
long-term if you're 22 you're crypto
long-term today you're more real estate
in crypto long-term 40 45
i cross over more conservative stuff
fair enough you've got no time to
recover
age age yeah fair enough let's continue
i can't tell you how that could
potentially
be the case so america americans cut
credit card there by nearly 83 billion
dollars during the pandemic according to
a study from wallet hub
a personal finance website americans
collectively
got rid of a record 83 billion dollars
of debt in 2020. the figure is
significant given that consumers have
added
an average of 54.2 billion dollars in
credit card that each year for the past
decade still the us has a long way to go
and paying off the one trillion dollars
of debt collectively
but it is progress wallet hub analyst
jill gonzales said that 2020 was the
second year
in more than 30 years we've ended the
year owing a less
credit card debt than we started with
the first year was 2009 the height
of the great recession thoughts i got to
tell you
this was one of the stories i was super
excited to even discuss yes i am
you said progress this is very
impressive stuff
right i mean we just we're talking about
investing right now yeah
are you long on crypto are you real
estate people forget
the best investment you can possibly
make is paying off your freaking credit
card
because if you're paying 10 12 15 20 24
interest rates you're not going to get
that in the market more like the 20s
right okay exactly i mean it could be 20
something percent
um so it's very interesting here and i
would love to get your opinion
on the correlation here two times in the
last 30 years
we've ended the year with what less
credit card debt than we started with
two times yeah 2020 pandemic
in 2009 the great recession
yeah so it seems to me that
fear you know produces
sort of fiscal prudence what's the
correlation with that
like i think you just said it okay is
that what it is it's like holy crap
the world is coming to an end it's an
epiphany moment for you was that what it
was save your damn moment
okay right so it's on top of the
leaderboard right now baby no i think
you're right it's very impressive i
think you're exactly if you're one of
those people out there
that took the opportunity to get your
stimulus check or make your money or not
travel and you actually did the
smart fiscal prudent thing and actually
paid off your credit card and said
i am not effing going back into debt
ever again kudos to you out there i have
respect for you
if you did that out there no i i think
you're absolutely right so you take
somebody's got 25 000 limit on a credit
card and they're sitting there at 15.
i may need this for something really
important and i can't go to restaurants
i can't travel
i'm probably lower on car maintenance
there's a lot of things that you just
weren't buying
at all for people living beyond their
means partying a little bit
and i think there was prudence in there
that says hey i've got a couple extra
dollars here i'm gonna
knock this down sitting at home with
time to think is actually good for
americans and i think generally
people sit at home a time to think will
make pretty rational decisions so in
okay uh uh barack obama's being
interviewed and he said
look these are times that you may want
to stay home and
skip that vegas trip okay he says that
and he says save that money right
instead of you know he said this [ __ ]
and i don't want to see any more than uh
ceo's going to vegas on those private
jets
i think that uh i think that stuff needs
to come to an end i think that's uh
wasteful got it remember that
remember we said that and all the
private jet companies and vegas like
flipped out and said we supported you
jerk
so he says this politics he says this
and all of a sudden out of nowhere
okay a friend out of las vegas the mayor
of las vegas oscar goodman comes out
and calls out barack obama how dare
you say such a thing about my city how
dare there's a guy that voted for him
how
dare you tell people to not come to the
great city of las vegas where all these
people have their jobs right
all this money being saved is a
beautiful thing but this money being
saved hits a lot of industries okay that
money would generally end up
in an industry it's going to go
somewhere it's going to be spent
somewhere which by the way i tell you i
like the fact that we're paying off debt
i'm all about paying off debt okay
unfortunately during covet the country
got into five
trillion dollars more debt so yeah we
paid off 83 billion dollars of
individuals credit card debt
but the country is officially five
trillion dollars and more debt which
means you're eventually
that 83 billion dollars may be sexy but
it ain't nothing
compared to what you're gonna have to
pay off your kids yourself in the next
10 20 30 40 50 years
possibly 100 years because that debt has
to be paid off with the 5 trillion
dollars of money that we printed so
the saying like you said you know fear
makes people save money
fear also sharpens listening people
listen more when they're afraid people
are willing to take advice when they're
afraid
unfortunately today fear is not really
sharpening listening to anybody because
they're not afraid today people are
pretty
aggressive today people are very
optimistic today people are playing
offense today so
everybody's thinking the market's going
to go galore and everyone's going to
make money and the dow's not going to
drop and
we saw a glimpse of it what happened
when the interest rates went up a couple
weeks ago two weeks ago when the rates
went up all of a sudden wait a minute
what's going on over here
you know you know market took a hit for
a day and of course it came back up but
you know this is good playing aggressive
offense like this paying dead off
but it'd be great to have this habit
during good
bad and ugly times yeah unfortunately
when you're staying home you have
nowhere to go to spend that money what
do you do
save them save that money thank you for
that uh tee up well
one just i guess counterpoint to our
good friend oscar goodman
um it's not you know it's the wrong
people
i just want you to so before i oscar was
you ever seen a movie casino of course
robert de niro he is in the movie and in
real life he was the attorney of tony
spelatra
frank colada and you know oscar is a a
very interesting story about oscar
goodman he was the mayor
of vegas for 12 years you know who was
the mayor after him
for eight years his wife has been though
did he play himself in the movie
i know exactly what you're talking about
yeah of course we had a great time with
him good man he's a good man
he's an interesting one um but you
brought up like how dare you
you know not spend your money in vegas
look it's not
i've had this conversation with people
before well why would i save
you know because you know if i spend
money that helps the economy
yeah and helps individual sectors yeah
listen it's not your
individual job to stimulate the freaking
economy
it's your job so you're more about
stimulating stimulating yourself you're
stimulating your own
pocket books don't worry don't worry
noble person you are okay
i'll be back in 10 minutes i'm just
saying
don't worry like worry about your own
jesus
jesus don't worry about what's going on
in the macro economy worry about what's
going on
under your roof like if you're in debt
don't you know
justify getting into more debt and
spending more money well
i'm helping the economy man don't worry
about that that'll that'll figure itself
out if you've got five thousand dollars
of credit card debt
and you have the opportunity to pay it
off get that out of your life self
stimulation stimulation i'll be right
back guys
yeah self stimulation focus on which by
the way i think you make a very good
point because
you know uh at the end of the day uh uh
you know even michael jackson said what
uh
if you want to make a change take a look
at yourself
and you know what i'm talking to the man
in the memory right starts with you yeah
it starts with you so we've gone all
over the place if you want to make the
world a better place take a look at
yourself and make that
change say it
the song you placed from the 60s that's
the song you wake up and we forgot what
was the song you wake up
what was the song you played here a
minute ago that just woke us up
tv brave on skull button it's a ghost
sing it sing it for us
well it doesn't have any words well then
then do that we're going to talk about
that
there you go that was a great girl thank
you steven
you know that's where it stops what kind
of music about
michael jackson be the man spack versus
by the way by the way if you're enjoying
the topics we've covered so far and the
fact that we have tom on
smash that subscribe button if you're
enjoying it so far press that subscribe
button we're trying to get this podcast
over 100 000
subscribers but let's talk about specs
versus ipos first of all
assume 80 of people listening to this
don't know what a spack is 20
do and they've heard about it so why is
everybody
talking about spax versus ipos got it
so a lot of people out there
entrepreneurs think about you know
having your own company and saying
you know how did facebook get on the
market how did twitter get on the market
well
you build your company up and then you
work with a new york bank a goldman
sachs morgan stanley merrill lynch folks
like that
and they do what's called ipo it initial
public offering and they get you on the
stock market
now the bank is in charge of all that
and a lot of times the bank
you know they got heavy fees and stuff
there's an alternative that's out there
it's called spax and it's like a short
way
for to get on the stock market and
what's very interesting
that i think that most people don't know
is how this
gets gamed because the money that your
company will get is the first
day ipo so when you go on the stock
market the company gets a bunch of money
on the first day and then the company's
traded on the stock market and then you
can take that money build your company
and do all these kind of great things so
faster version of going public rather
than taking the ipo
correct correct and you know what's very
interesting and i was
giving example many people you don't
have to understand it's backer ipo to
notice hey that company just went public
and they see this
jump in the spot yeah stock price yeah
wall street bets will tell you about it
if you're on robin hood you see it all
about it it's very easy to see you don't
really have to
denote a lot of details and notice it
and hey kai
put up on poshmark so you have poshmark
really cool company
uh where people are reaching to their
closets taking fashion and they can
trade itself
secondhand retail that's right and it's
like a it's like an ebay
for curated fashion where you can sell
what's in your closet that's not too old
so poshmark goes out on day one they
sold ipo or a spec
ipo and it was goldman and morgan that
walked hand in hand down the aisle to do
this one
so they went out and a bunch of people
at gold
high net worth people at goldman ipo
were invited to buy in at about 42 to 49
look what happens within two days all
the way up to 100
and then this one just happened in
january and then it goes down you know
why it went
because all those people goldman and
morgan those high net worth people that
saw the thing pop day one
they're like i've just doubled i'm out
and so now it levels out down to a more
rational where is it today like 50 or
something yeah
51 so it's it's above its ipo value a
little bit and now it's going to grow
into it
still make 25 you're just gonna make 100
that's exactly right but the point is
that popped there
if that was really the value of the
company this should have gone out maybe
at 75
and that would have been more dollars
for poshmark on day one
they got the first day price like 49. so
it's kind of games so the ipo game
is kind of game by the base in the ipo
game who wins in the who wins in the ipo
game
the ipo game the banks win and the high
net worth people
and the big institutions that buy your
ipo price
the day before the pop and then they
sell out
that's in the ipo that's that's the ipa
who wins in the spec the spac
the the company still gives up a percent
of itself to go public
but the but the pricing is much more
rational
and you work with the spec partner and
it's just it's more rational
and you have less of this hidden game
this day one day week one game
and so i i the bad side of facts right
now is there's too many spacks
and so there if there's too many specs
and not enough good companies
bad companies are going to get out
because some spac will say
well you're not really that perfect yet
but i'll take you public
what's a bad company not a real product
no it's just future projections you
don't have past projections you're just
kind of like
here's what we're going to do next three
years and you say what have you done
last three years and you have nothing to
show for yourself
growth is less stable you're profitable
not there maybe you're a little so let
me ask you this if i have if i created a
spec myself and you and i put a couple
hundred million dollars and we're
doing it at ten dollars with 50 cent
warrant you know whatever that's exactly
right okay so say we have that
right okay we put a couple hundred
million dollars in there what kind of
companies
are we not looking for to put in the
spac
and what kind of companies are we
looking for to consider
putting into our spec three-year-old
venture company that hasn't yet grown
into profitability and gotten above 25
million in sales
is probably sketchy so don't touch that
one don't touch it but they're touching
it and that's where
yeah shit's hitting the fan correct okay
that's the criticism of stacks is that
the
lower quality companies are getting out
because there's too many spacks out
there
um right now it's like uh you know
there's
great companies out there that
entrepreneurs putting together they're
going to get out
so pat you brought up something
yesterday because
but give me the other one give me the
other one that you would we have a
couple hundred million ten dollars
metro mile just went out with us back
yeah i think highly of them they're
redoing car insurance over 100 million
dollars in sales and so
it's a real legitimate company
legitimate companies waiting 18 months
going 90 days and go with a spec
yeah exactly right mm-hmm are you ready
you got to be ready for it speaking of
metro mile you did
a case study metro mile versus root i
watched it i tried to
you know not only am i on valuetainment
economics i
um watch it i'm a subscriber because i
learned from the biz doc the hair club
for men i'm also a customer
exactly i'm not only am i the president
i'm uh
i'm also a customer yeah you're gonna
like the way you look i guarantee you
tom
but anyway i listened to to that episode
it was you were in hawaii lucky you
doing episodes from hawaii looking good
drinking a mai tai i believe you were
slightly drunk but we're not calling you
out but you're having a good time but
you were doing an episode
on the spack of the last last five
minutes of the case study it was a
little inebriated
a little a little shaky at the end but
it's all good thomas you remember doing
the case study
that's right study i remember that
and then you did uh you know it was
metro mile versus root
um it was actually very informative but
i i mean i'm
of the eighty percent that was like what
the hell is this back i never even heard
about us back until basically
our good friend chamath palapatiya
started talking about it over the last
yeah
you know 12 months he's all about it
he's all about that life
but and he's got the track record he's
got the track record he did well
you brought up something yesterday pat
um when i said well what's the deal with
this back and you said it's all about
speed
it's all about speed it takes less time
so anyway
what is i mean if you want to go public
it can cost you four to ten million
dollars i'm giving a low to high it's
about a six million dollar number is
that about a right number
absolutely fair the ton of things you
have to do so four to ten million
dollars legal fees
cpa accounting audits headaches you're
probably
you're gonna have a handful of people in
your office for six months just sitting
there going through
every single thing to prepare and then
goldman morgan merrill whoever it is
that's going to take you they're going
to go
telling you how beautiful you are it's
they're going to have to go sell you
it's a mess when you go
public through the ipo spec boom 90 days
if you're good we're out and you're on
the market ding ding ding ding ding
if you're on the market if you go
through the spec uh
if you have a real business if you don't
have a real business guess what they
will do if you go on a spec
you will be trashed by the media oh my
god if it's not a real business why
would they trash you what is it because
it's fake
it's you're trying to make money by
manipulating the stock and saying here's
what we're creating here's who we're
going to be here's what we're building
but you don't have any of that
built today and if you keep saying
here's what we're going to do watch
watch us watch us and nothing happens
with the watches people are patient for
a month maybe three months maybe six
months maybe 12 months
but eventually if you can't show proof
in the pudding of what you're creating
that's when backlash comes let me let me
ask you another question professional
analysts
are out there a lot of this is sort of
big macro economics should i go spark
shall i go ipo
how does this affect our listeners out
there like what should they be aware of
is it when they're investing or they're
looking to allocate their capital is it
just
knowledge where where should our
listeners be first of all
education is key but this isn't even
about the education i'll give a
completely different angle of it
tom is sitting here for people that
don't know tom if you know tom tom is a
guy that did very well in business if
you've ever you ever seen the interview
between steve jobs and
bill gates the last great interview
between the two and the red chair you
know which one i'm talking about pull up
the picture don't play the video because
in case
you know the folks out of silicone start
knocking on the door put steve jobs bill
gates last interview
interview yeah you probably have seen it
i mean the world
saw that picture right there with them
going at it like it was
very very emotional it was intense it
was awesome right
there was 300 people in that room tom
was one of them
okay that were invited to be in that
room tom was a silicon valley guy tom
was a technology guy tom was a guy that
participated in four companies going and
they sold it for over a billion dollars
that's what tom's resume is former
professor
adjunct professor at pepperdine i think
loyola mountain am i missing one of them
iowa biola was what he was teaching so i
mean he's no rocket scientist but he's
doing no rocket scientists but his dad
was that was a rocket scientist
son of a rocket son of a rocket
scientist but but the point the point is
the following
if you have the ability
to go run with a person you believe in
that you think is crazy enough to do
what they're saying they're going to do
it
and you go you become a voice you become
a leader you own a piece of that company
and that company takes off and you own
some shares
and you bring value to that company you
can experience some nice exits
i lived in communities my last 10 15
years i live in communities where people
you talk to them how did you make your
money you'll hear them say uh
it was either the inheritance is
actually a very small percentage less
than 10 percent
self-made millionaires 90 self-made
billionaires yes that is the 70
that self-made 30 that the money was you
know passed on like the walton family
all these other guys but 70
of billionaires 90 of millionaires are
self-made right how did you make your
money
oh you know real estate how did you make
your money oh stocks how'd you make your
money
i was part of a company the company went
public i own some shares
i was there early i got my exit i got my
16 million auto check
you don't know this person i got my 22
million auto check i got my 41 million
the world doesn't know 40 million dollar
people yeah you
you could you could be sitting next to a
guy that's got 42 million dollars from
an exit that he had and he's sitting
pretty he's set
he's got good things good life all so
anybody that's watching this and you're
hearing
us talk about ip or spec my challenge
and
you know sort of an inspiration to you
would be try to figure right away to get
into that circle and go contribute to a
company that's potentially going to go
public or have a spec or you know be
of value to that company the upside
could be exponential even mario
mario was a guy that started with me
early you know you got mario morale
you know tikrin who start alexis and
then you got some of the guys from amore
big you know uh uh tom himself thomas
tom's uh
you know one the biggest shareholders uh
in the entire company tom i think tom
you're like the third biggest
shareholder in the company third or
fourth biggest shareholder in the couple
got a smile on his face
right third or fourth biggest
shareholder in the company so but if you
go back and you think about jose gaitan
right jose marlene guyton big
shareholder right you think about
a palayo you think about a uh uh
a uh uh even sapalas that came later on
so
these guys come in they get and by the
way there's a lot we have like
250 of them but some more than less you
come in
you get the shares you contribute the
company does well then you have an exit
so i think what i take away from ipos
and spax is
go find one and bring the ton of value
to that company with the hopes of
earning the rights to get some shares so
hopefully you can have your own exit as
well
one day that's how i process that when i
see that
do you have feedback on that time what
are you right no absolutely he's just
smiling over there
i'll tell you about a guy there is some
going back at jam dad there was a
producer a games producer
and if he's listening he knows who he is
travis and
travis wanted wanted to know how do i
get more equity
how do i get more equity and he wanted
to know how do i build value
for the organization how do i build the
organization's value and
he never was a guy that came in and said
hey you know
you know they're they're they're hiring
over at electronic arts or act division
can i have another 10 grand a year in
salary he
never never never said that's what she
has he had what he asked for shares but
more importantly he was like
how do i how do i impart the valuation
of the company and by the way
you that's the attitude that patrick
just said that's the attitude you walk
in
hey how does my job increase the value
of this company i just want to know how
i can be really really good at it
i need health insurance so i gotta have
enough to live and do things like that
but i'm willing to make a bet here
and drive on value yeah and you walk in
there you're gonna have an entrepreneur
hug you and say
i will take care of you and this is how
you do it fyi we just recently uh uh
interviewed an executive i won't give
the name okay here's how the interview
went
uh look pay me whatever salary you want
to pay me it's great whatever you want
to pay me pay me the salary
but i'm more interested in equity and
participating the victory
so pay me there i don't care what my
salary is
let me participate in this that comes
from a person with experience
okay and then when you learn more about
the person you realize right the person
says
pay me inequity not in because he
had an exit in the past or one or two or
three
exits in the past so you you had a guy
that was working for you years ago goes
to snap has an exit gets 40 million
bucks and he was a guy that reported to
you
correct that's a pretty nice exit to
have right so those things
happen to a lot of people uh
that's the part about working for an
established company and that's the part
about working for a company that's
steadily grown we can have a big upside
by the way if you're enjoying it you're
learning
press that subscribe button and if you
want us to answer a question you may
have go send a tweet
with pbd podcast once again pbd podcast
my handle is that patrick may david kai
is watching all the questions that are
coming in
we're going to get to a question here as
well but let's continue to the next
topic of russia i want to do russia next
we'll get to that one as well
russia slowed down twitter speed and
threatened a total block
after the site allegedly failed to
delete
banned content if twitter continues to
ignore the requirements of the law
the enforcement measured will be
continued
the state communication regulator said
think about that
the move which escalates a grown
standoff between moscow and u.s social
media comes weeks after russian
authorities accuse twitter
and others are failing to delete posts
it said
illegally urge children to take part in
the anti-kremlin protest
the regulators claims that the vast
majority of the post twitter allegedly
refused to delete contained content
encouraging minors to take their own
lives other police including
in the indecent images of children and
information about drug abuse moscow has
a
gradually introduced tougher internet
laws in recent years requiring secret
search engines to delete some search
results messaging services to share
encryption keys
etc etc etc tom what do you by the way
russia tried to ban telegram messenger
since 2018 for example but proved
technically unable to block the app
and last year he publicly lifted the ban
what do you think russia is doing here
going after twitter
um i think there's a there is a not so
humorous
truth that's in the middle of that and
that is you are encouraging children to
take their own lives
what are you talking about you're
encouraging them to speak against the
government
oh i see so you're that's how you take
your own life you speak against the
government
and you get disappeared right um look
russia hey russia really hasn't changed
that much i mean since the soviet union
broke
you know they've been trying to put it
back together and the biggest thing
you're trying to put back together is
your control systems
and information you know and
human yearning for freedom are
things that are catalysts for massive
change and the government doesn't want
change i think it's as simple as that
and this window to the world they don't
want it this soapbox to speak
um they don't want it ronald reagan told
a great joke
and he said he was talking to a russian
friend
and he says i think the united states
great for the freedom they said why do
you say that
and ronald reagan said because any
citizen in america
can walk in to the president's office
and pound his fist on the table and say
mr reagan i don't like how you're
running your country
and the russian guy says i can do that
too so what do you mean i can walk into
gorbachev's office i can pound my fist
on the table and i said i don't like how
mr reagan's running his country
and i don't think anything's changed
it's just these digital russia still
russia russia still russia how much of
this liability
is on twitter how much of this is
backfiring on twitter based on how they
mishandled
prior incidents uh i think they need to
be careful that
arrogance against american controls
doesn't play well
other places like china and russia how
how ugly could this get i mean what can
russia really do to twitter let's face
it what can
what do you do you can't you can't bomb
a social media platform and say i'm
going to blow you up twitter
well what do you do i think it's great
hackers i mean we all know russia's got
great hackers we're going to talk about
a little later but microsoft right now
is under a state-sponsored attack from
china yep
so i you've got some smart people over
there
and i think you know digital attacks
digital warfare i i think that's exactly
where they go with this okay
well i mean back to your initial thought
uh you know of complaining against the
the government of uh of russia obviously
putin's in charge there
what's the name of the gentleman who's
been the biggest dissident and uh
detractor of uh
putin and nexi alexei navalny right
we've heard we've we've seen this guy's
story over the germans
took three months in hospitals okay so
he was poisoned on a plane we saw we we
played that
that video sort of in one of the initial
podcast yep he's back in the plane
oh my god they take him off the plane
turns out he was poisoned and clearly
this was a germany savings
life germany saves his life shout out to
your people and
uh i'm canadian by the way okay i didn't
you know just go along with it baby
um the um
what does this guy do he you know
recovers and what does he he goes back
to russia
and essentially dares putin to kill him
again he gets arrested where's it what's
the status of him now is he puts him on
trial and puts him in a tough prison
that's where he's there right now is he
not
i i don't know that's my point is that
you speak out about against the
government
uh poisoned you know imprisoned
good luck out there i mean back to your
point about the
russian joke back to your point with
twitter how do you fight
a social media company if you're a
strong man like putin it's just
hacking digital warfare is that the only
um
outlet you have to doing something like
that that's the question
kai what can they really do to twitter
can they do anything to twitter outside
of having
you can't poison twitter or can you tom
can they do anything to twitter you
don't have an answer for that
i think they just shut it off right
because wrestler controls
the internet over there yeah they'll
shut up they limit
they limit access so nobody into in
russia yeah
but can they do anything to the actual
network of i think just
tweeting or hacking bots kind of that
stuff well they can do some stuff which
obviously can do damage because remember
the bitcoin scam that happened with
twitter
on the users and stuff like that well
according to cnn they can steal
elections
it's uh it's it's proven by cnn folks
cnn said it you know it's just of course
clearly that's your community so
okay so let me let me let me give a
shout out to a few people here that gave
some uh
some uh contributed to the podcast today
um let's see what this one is here
florida seems to be a great place for
people that want to escape new york
for many of the obvious reasons what are
the material cons that you have
come across about living in florida that
people just have to accept by moving
there where a family with young children
ask
jack husso he gave a hundred dollars and
he's that's actually a real question
he's asking
what's your question says he's asking
what is the risk and negative side of
living in florida if you would have said
a negative part of living you lived in
boca for many years
you've been here your entire life minus
the uh exciting
addison addison but what is the negative
and the con of living in florida
so a it depends on where you're at in
florida so if you're in the panhandle
that's a lot different than
living in south florida true versus
central florida or if you're on the west
coast
the first thing that comes to mind is um
hurricane season so without hurricane
season
uh in florida there's not a lot of
downside to being here
uh obviously you know the the jobs
aren't as
a plentiful as they are in new york city
or in california or in silicon valley or
anything like that
because typically we haven't had the
industry that
um influx of companies coming out here
but now things have changed
so i think people are starting to get
wise so i think the biggest
clearly the weather's on your side
clearly um
you know the the sun the fun like
there's all that in florida it's just
can i make money there what are the jobs
so i always tell people that move here
from
new york city if you keep that type of
attitude it doesn't
necessarily need to be new york exactly
but if you keep that type of
i'm going to crush it i'm going to get
out there wake up every day and grind
and do my thing and
and get to work and get to business if
you bring that attitude to florida
you will crush it because florida is
very correct especially in south florida
very
latin american influence like you know
chill okay
back you know they say you're running on
cuban time which is basically like
the meeting's at 9. i don't man i'll be
there at 9 45
i'll be there when i be there it's all
good it's a very relaxed kind of you
know you know retiree
the only negative that you're going to
say is hurricane and the fact that
there's the pool of talent is not as
high as la new york silicon valley but
it's getting better
but it's getting better what would you
say negative tom i i would say that i
said that
the economy here is thin it's not thick
so you have a thin economy of jobs over
here and it's
largely a service economy where
everybody is working
in the city serving each other if you
know what i mean
and there's there's not like hubs of
industry necessarily yeah
um there's there's not like a a a
silicon beach
if you will so i think you know
you're going to be working in
hospitality and service industries and
regional offices of like state farm
insurance and things like that
schools down here public schools
typically have not been the way they are
say in the northeast
so there's a couple things like that and
let's face it the great weather in the
winter
is you know countered with the tough
weather in the summer and you've got
hurricane season and stuff like that so
i think there's cons but i think there's
cottons everywhere you live
right but for for a solid eight nine
months
south florida there's literally not a
better heaven on the planet to be
like for sure i mean look if you want
even if you're in the redneck riviera
where you like to uh
to hang out then you say you've been
there the panhandle i've i've
been i have been to television who was
it that goes to destin
who's someone sitting in this chair
shriner streiner goes there
when he visits here he's trying to go
straight even it's nice up there well i
talked to him no i talked about that
okay i gotcha i'm not going crazy no no
you're not it's like a ton of people
from
dallas houston uh they go to destin
there you go as a
um a more affordable kind of spring
break it's beautiful
great you know it's not like cheap stuff
great
vrbo stuff there two families share it
it's great by the way here's what you
got to be thinking about if you got a
family you said family and kids right
okay
uh living in south florida you're two
and a half hours away from orlando which
is disney world and you've got
universal city uh universal studios over
there so that's that part
yeah if you want to rent a yacht for the
weekend and take the kids to
bimini which is what two hours away
you'll spend a couple thousand dollars
and go
with your family of four and food and
all that have a good time and come back
up if you want to go to key west if you
want to go to
cuba if you want to go to the caribbean
if you want to go to europe you're eight
hours away if you want to go to new york
you're two and a half hours away if you
want to go to
you know you got so many different ops
sports they got all the sports
you got marlins you got the heat you got
the uh uh
they got all sports right obviously it's
not the craziest time today with sports
when the lebron was here they were doing
well when
dan marino was here different story we
haven't had anything crazy going on with
the sport what do you mean last year
that he went to the finals
tampa bay lightning i don't know if i
would put
you know like the level of excitement of
an la or
you know nets or something like that
spoiled out in l.a you're winning
it is worth a championship do you want
to you were at the world series i mean
it is what it is and it's a place
right now where just yesterday had a
call with our buddy tim
and he was whispering to me about uh you
know how goldman is moving one of their
divisions here we already know that
that's public
you know peter's saying you know some of
these stories that have already come out
tons of them
but there is another one that's way way
bigger
than goldman that is moving out to south
florida that it's a hundred percent
they've announced it they're coming out
you're going to hear about the next
couple days
it's more and more that are making the
move out you're not going to announce it
i cannot announce it because you know
anyways so there's more and more people
that are making the move in south
florida
okay that that's taking place but heat
you'll experience heat humidity and
hurricane when it comes and when it
happens i'll let you know how it goes
because i've been
i've been through wars i've been through
bombing i've been through tornado i've
been through
earthquakes many of them and i guess the
next one is i have to kind of have the
trifecta yeah maybe not a trifecta it's
a point effect uh
we just missed out on the snowstorm
though dallas yeah
well let me just say one thing i don't
know if you've been over for hurricane
season
i look at hurricane season in florida
versus whatever the hell goes on in
california
wildfires and earthquakes and mudslides
i'll take my month of hurricanes before
uh
you know it's like it's like right and
the guy says in about five seconds i'm
gonna punch you in the face
and it's gonna be tough so you got five
seconds to move okay
versus the guy punches you in the face
okay
earthquake doesn't give you the warning
no hurricane tells you in five seconds
i'll be there in five days
what do you want to do yeah exactly
something you know you may want to leave
so anyways next question we got here
five dollars from gtr a23 pat how do you
see the chance of texas separating from
the united states
and what you're taking all this massive
migration coming to the following states
um you know yesterday i was being
interviewed by nomad capitalist the guy
named andrew
who has lived in a hundred different
countries and he teaches people
how to have dual citizenships and he
owns uh properties in five different
countries is what he does he's all about
leave
america because there's better places to
live
than america he asked me a question he
says
are you an america fan i said die hard
he says tell me what you mean by that
i said i'm a die-hard america fan of
what it was founded on
america to me is the values of
principles which is what freedom of
speech freedom of assembly freedom of
religion freedom of
your second amendment free enterprise
that stuff the moment that changes
it's no longer america to me it's a
completely different
name to me so the moment certain states
and what california is experiencing
right now as well as new york when
you're 20 years old guess where you want
to live
you want to live in la you want to live
in well you live in miami partying in
miami it's probably going to be better
than partying in l.a quite frankly if
you think about it miami party is pretty
legit
so but when you're younger you're like
i'm in la hollywood i'm in new york city
all this stuff and you start kind of
making money
and you start having a family and you
start kind of saying well i just
don't know if these are some of the you
know things that i want to be around
i want to kind of have a little bit more
flexibility and freedom then you start
looking
and then if america goes on the tipping
point and they really start pushing
around
the populace i i just think it would be
like you know how with business when you
see somebody that's totally screwing up
like sears is screwing up you're leaving
an opportunity okay for others to come
in
when you saw blockbuster royally getting
arrogant as an
eight billion dollar company screwing up
with the late fees remember how annoying
it was with blockchain dude
just wipe it wait take it off no i said
i'm paying you 30 bucks for this movie
to buy brand new it's 15 bucks
waive the damn late fee put a limit of
the value of the dvd
no i'm not going to be doing it yours 30
bucks after doing that to tens of
thousands of people you're like you know
what i'm sorry i just can't stand the
way you treat customers
i'm out of here now there's only one
left and we interviewed the manager the
one blockbuster that's left
i don't know where it's at seattle or
washington or something like that
i think today there's a great
opportunity
for a handful of countries to become a
second option
i think today's a great opportunity for
a handful of countries to say you know
what
we kind of see america that's been what
everybody wanted to be like
what if we see the mistakes america's
made and we give that safety to people
to come over here
what if we change it up okay what if we
change it up how many people are gonna
move
not many but all it takes is a couple
people that move
influential and then if and only if
america
royally gets cocky arrogant egotistical
kind of like the city of detroit
went from 200 000 people to 1.8 and next
thing you know the municipalities
those city employees the government
people started kind of pushing people
around
ford said listen forget about it you're
right we're out of here people started
leaving they went from 1.8 million
people living in new york city the
richest city in the world
to you know 700 000 people living there
today if you call
9-1-1 i don't know if we covered this on
the last podcast if you call 9-1-1 in
in detroit city today it's the r is the
poorest city and it's the most dangerous
city to live in america today today
poorest and most dangerous lowest it's
the worst city today based on
economical freedom and safety right you
call 9-1-1 today do you know how long it
takes for cops to show up
59 minutes let me say this one more time
if you dial 9-1-1
it takes more than 50 minutes for cops
to show up
if you call 9-1-1 today you call him you
tell him
kai said this in the room you call him
you tell him i'm about to rob the bank
you go rob the bank it takes you 20
minutes to do it you leave and they
still haven't shown up
right so what does this mean with
america if america gets too cocky and
arrogant start pushing people around
i think people will be looking at going
elsewhere if you look at a lot of people
where are you from oh i'm irish
their family left ireland to come here
where are you from i'm jewish okay your
family left israel
where are you from norway your family
left were you from mexico mifa iran
where are you
so if people from other countries are
willing to move to a country like this
people will be eventually forced to
leave america if america gets too cocky
you guys have any opposing opinions on
what i just said
i know you want to say like marco was uh
just
look obviously we're all very
pro-american and
and we love it here but you know it's
easy to say well you know just leave
america oh i'll just leave him right but
where are you actually going did you
hear what i said earlier yeah
okay what did i say regarding what i
said if
same way blockbuster lost people this is
a great
opportunity to be a netflix i agree with
you so a
uh uh a uh uh belize a
costa rica not canada
i know a lot of people that moved to
costa rica dubai
is a place that's attracting a lot of
people now living there is a different
kind of a lifestyle so you're going to
have to ask about the pool of talent
the benefits of talent so the guy asked
me question he says you know he he was
in uh
somewhere in central america where he
was at the country he was staying at
i said so for he says would you consider
us a certain industry could do that not
all industries could do that like he's a
guy that does online courses
things like that you can live where
anywhere engineers anywhere coders
anywhere certain industries you can't go
anywhere
so the challenge would be the only
challenge when i processes it is what
pool pool of talent but if you have a
place
i tell you right now if we had a country
i'm telling you right now if we had a
country right now somehow somewhere we
got 10 million people
and we got a good amount of land right
now decent weather some natural
resources
watch what we would do to that country
20 years later i'm telling you right now
if we had a country right now with 10
million people decent natural resources
some land give us 20 years look what we
would do to our citizens
look how much they would love living
where we live look the kind of
foundation and the values and principles
we will build that country and look what
kind of people would want to live with
us
and you know what we would do we
wouldn't allow everybody to come in
it wouldn't be one of those situations
where it's like a it would be by
invitation just like you know if you
want to be part of clubhouse what do
they do
you have to be invited right okay back
in the days a lot of these social media
platforms you have to be what
you have to be invited it'd be a similar
thing hey you're going to say pat i
think we got to let keith
in here tell me about keith dude we're
going to love keith let me what are you
talking about
have i ever brought anybody okay cool
bring keith in i think there would be an
element of that that we could build a
country with invite only yeah that was
the
origination of facebook remember that it
was it was college by college and you
had to be
a student at that college those are the
emails that you had so
so i agree i don't see a valid viable
option to today there are some singapore
new zealand there are some
singapore is an option new zealand is an
option and quite frankly those would
probably at the top five of places you
would look at
costa rica isn't when i went to panama
city panama not panama city
like spinnakers or you know club la
villa i'm talking panama
city panama next to nicaragua yes when i
went to panama city and i played poker
with the senator
i'm sitting there with them and i said
so where are you from oh i'm from dallas
oh very cool you vacation here often
he says no i've been living here for 11
years i said why did you leave so do you
know the regulations here
unemployment here is 2.3 percent they
leave you alone you can do anything
yours
have you looked at the real estate in
panama if i go to panama type in panama
real estate panama city panama real
estate
like buildings buildings buildings you
got to put buildings right
uh panama city buildings yeah uh
buildings uh
i hope it goes to the right panama city
put images like
right there like you ever seen anything
like that in u.s the fnf tower i've
never seen anything like this in u.s
right you you look at some of the right
there click on that one right there
luxury real estate look at that you know
you see some of the most beautiful stuff
now obviously i'm seeing stuff like this
in miami but
he says have you seen what we're doing
in panama city the next guy where are
you from chicago how long have you come
here
i've been living here for 10 years so
that gave a glimpse and i was 10 years
ago that gave me a glimpse that people
are considering moving to other
countries
from the u.s no no doubt and i know a
lot of people
especially people in south florida that
end up in costa rica what have you i i
guess my
point was yeah little pockets here go to
costa rica a little
you know maybe you go to little panama
like little tiny countries
maybe you end up in new zealand i guess
my macro question is what country is
going to supplant
america i just don't see one right now
and i'm not being a cocky american like
oh you can't
compete with america i just like paul
joked and said canada i don't know if he
was joking or not
go check out the weather in canada nine
months out of the year good luck over
there so i'm just saying
you want to go to china go have fun in
china check it out in michigan
or you know well that's what you can
move from michigan oh wait a minute
no no no wait a minute let me ask you
this what was the richest city in the
world in 1950s
motown baby what was the temperature in
motown
80 degrees year round do you know the
temperature in motion
that was because of uh thomas ford and
you know the industrial revolution and
making the cars and
which or is you just or his brother
henry ford i mean uh thomas i was
thinking of thomas edison henry ford you
just
thomas ford nikola ford right here
without trying to make a point is one
man changed a city one
it didn't take 50. it didn't take a
hundred
one person changed the city
forever ford came in created jobs
everybody moved in other automakers went
there mo tank came out of there michael
jackson diana ross
you know all of those names of who came
out meaning the
the records who signed them all of that
is from motown
detroit okay they call it the paris of
the west
a paris of the midwest detroit so and
weather sucked there it's not about the
weather don't get me wrong i give credit
to california whether it's got to be the
miami weather totally i get it weather
is very important
i'm not going to go i was about to move
to naperville chicago a friend of mine
jeff had a place
i was going to go i wanted to run with
the guy for a couple decades right but
i'm like yeah i'm good i'm
much better being in la or much better
being in florida but that's my
preference
but if it comes down to it and they
force people
would rather follow a leader an
environment that gives you
safety and freedom and they'll give up
a little bit of weather they'll give up
a little bit of other things to have
freedom there's nothing in your life
that's more important to you than
freedom
nothing when you have it you don't know
you have it you know how
when you when your body is doing well
you don't think about
any potential pain then you start having
back pain
and in which you say i'll give anything
to get rid of this back pain
then you get covet you're throwing up
all over the place say
it i'll give anything i'll give anything
to get rid of this right
yeah when you have freedom you don't
know you have it people don't know
they have freedom they don't know so but
when it's taken away then you're gonna
say
there's no way in the world i can live
like this for the rest of my life i'm
willing to go to a different place
because i just want to be free uh just
so um listen the chance of us getting
there's less than one percent just so
people know it's not a big chance we're
not putting
going to vegas right now betting a
hundred thousand dollars because you
know america is
going to go down but that one percent
chance is a chance where you should have
a hedge
you should hedge against it and have
your own insurance policy in case things
do happen and can i clarify one thing
uh adam kind of made fun when i was
talking about canada
i was talking more vancouver which a lot
of americans have been moving to
in montreal freezing they have been
stealing business from hollywood a lot
of productions are going to canada
and doing a good point and so those were
two of the examples i was thinking of
when i said canada has a huge
opportunity they've already
uh pounced on that opportunity and i
could see them continuing to grow
that's just my bottom it's just a very
powerful
uh point you just made with what's
happening over there with austin even
getting p business away from hollywood
and
by the way jack hasso said i'll donate
five dollars if adam isn't
allowed to sing ever again so i just
want to make sure jack said that so jack
i have to
uh give you that shot hey tom looks like
you want to say something about this
no i think i think uh i did but you've
covered it
so okay pat one counterpoint with that
but
is aren't you like the the detroit
example because my dad's from detroit i
ended up moving to florida in the 60s so
i'm familiar with this
but aren't you sort of highlighting the
beauty of america it's like well if
you're unhappy in that state
move to a different state that means
exactly what's playing out right now
with california new york and why people
are moving to florida
tennessee texas isn't that
sort of the point of america that you
know states rights that
certain states are screwing up like you
did an awesome video about is new york
the next detroit
you can move to a different state right
you don't have to move to a different
country i just don't see the country
yeah that's gonna but
usurp america sure if federal
government has more power than state
level the state didn't decide to get a
1.9
trillion dollar stimulus but that 1.9
trillion dollar stimulus
affects people living in any state
including south dakota that maybe wasn't
affected by covey fair enough
like a place like california was
affected by so yes federally
you are still getting side effects of
bad decisions being made at the top of
the government you will be affected by
it
all i'm saying is this is a great time
for another country to position
themselves
when rick perry was coming to the state
of california and he was saying
you're running you've heard me say this
you're running a business you're not
happy regulation come to texas come to
texas now guess who's doing it today
desantis is doing it guess who's the
most hate guess who are the two of the
most hated governors in america today
who are two of the most hated governors
in america cuomo and our friend
uh in california abbott and desantis
absolutely abbott and december you mean
abbot and the only reason cuomo is
by the way cuomo okay cuomo
you know what's next if he doesn't
resign let's talk about cuomo
if cuomo doesn't resign you know the
whole story came out yesterday so well
first of all he florida with me he
touched my face a new story
hot dog he told me to eat the whole
sausage he told me to do this he told me
to do that with
daughter sitting right next to him
yesterday story comes he put his hand
under my blouse and he groped my breasts
right another story that comes up okay
you know what's next
you know what's next here's what's next
if cuomo doesn't resign they have 20
other stories
they're just sprinkling it they're not
putting all of it out slowly and they're
telling cool
listen do you not think a call behind
closed doors is happening and the call
goes something like this with the people
who have the real power
not cuomo here's what the call sounds
like um
andrew it's time there is no way in the
world my dad
would be to grave turn i would never
resign do you know what this means to my
family's legacy
i would discipli i get it andrew but we
have 10 more stories
and we have the story you don't want us
to talk about
so each week we're going to put a new
story
until you finally resign we're telling
you resign
now i'm not going to do it okay watch
the news tomorrow
news story coming out enjoy your
thursday
you wake up a woman comes out another
one you know
saying that he's like oh [ __ ] okay
hey uh andrew yeah so are you ready
to resign no way you're not gonna bully
me
i'm a new yorker you're not gonna do me
my italian descent
okay another story is gonna come out
monday
i can tell you stories are going to come
out until this guy resigns and by the
way it's not republicans doing it
it's democrats doing it to him i talked
to ron kim new york state assemblyman
who is part of the whole aoc camp and
bernie sanders camp
cannot stand cuomo okay for what he did
with the
old folks nursing homes is what he did
and kim is not crazy these are not crazy
these are
mainstream democrats these are
level-headed people they're yeah freaks
i'm talking to ron ron you know listen
don't get me wrong he's a socialist
proud he's a guy that's progressive yes
he's a guy that's on that side but
behind closed doors he's getting pushed
out
non-stop he is eventually going to get
pushed out
non-stop if he if he doesn't resign
expect
a story to come out every single week
that's my prediction i may be wrong
but i think behind closed doors there's
20 other stories that are waiting to
come out one
once every week until the guy finally
says you know how it's going to happen
here's how it's going to happen
um mom's going to call chris is going to
call
and they're going to say look bro i'm
just telling you
i'm telling you right now it's time
just do it bro i don't care i'm going to
back you up but you go out there and do
it
okay forget about it we've had a great
life we've done well for ourselves
these guys are now trashing our family
daughter doesn't know my niece doesn't
need to hear this
it's time and he's gonna say what are
you talking about dad mario would have
said
i get it but this is a very unique
situation it's enough
we got to do it and i still have your
back i think that's what it could lead
to i hope it doesn't but i think that's
what it's going to lead to where he's
going to have to resign so
the two of the most hated governors in
america today are who abbott and
desantis why you know you know when i
talked to ron kim yesterday
he said something very interesting and i
was like why would you say that he said
he said i don't think it's a good
strategy to recruit citizens from other
states to your state purely
based on economy i'm like that's the
whole idea
what are you talking about people went
to new york because you're recruiting
people
to economy and he said he made a comment
which
by the way i can't wait to have ron back
again we had a great hour conversation
in this course
and there was a debate and banter where
he's saying his side is like well i know
who you are of course i follow your
stuff
but i got to tell you here's what i
stand you came in america we both came
here as immigrants i'm 41 you're 42.
my dad owned a uh liquor store or a
grocery store after 10 years they had to
shut it down and all this other stuff
and i said okay so you have personal
experience as i said you went to this
you decided to go into business i went
into public
so you wanted to be an entrepreneur i
went to public he said
i don't think it's a good strategy to
take people away from businesses and
then i said
what about the fact that a division of
goldman sachs is leaving peter's saying
all this stuff is leaving
and he says yeah we it's okay that
financial people are they didn't say
it's okay that financial people are
leaving but he's saying
it's the financial folks that are
leaving but we're building our own tech
hub like silicon valley in new york city
that's what's growing if the financial
people do what they do
let them do what they do but we're
building a technology
center like a hub like a silicon valley
in new york city
so you know it's it's uh it's
interesting but more power to desantis
and
abbott but imagine if now it's a country
now imagine you're a president and you
go
and you have an accent whatever part of
the world you are hey this is president
such and such
okay and you go on the media and you're
talking 50 different media platforms bbc
whatever all these other places sky news
australia all these places you talk and
you say
americans i can't believe i'm saying
this
but from a person who admires your
country and what it was founded on i am
surprised on what is happening today
to your country here's a country that
was able to do in 200 years what china
couldn't do in 2000 years
here's a country that was able to go
from nothing
just because of some land you became the
most powerful country in the world
here's a country that went from having
this kind of a gdp to doing this kind of
a gdp
here's a country that gave birth to
rockefeller franklin
chase you go through the list of great
entrepreneurs
but unfortunately we all know you're no
longer
the america you used to be and if you're
somebody that's looking at options
let me explain to you what we at our
country
are doing we protect this we
protect that the five concerns that you
may face is this this this
here's how we have protected your long
term and all i suggest
is before you even think about moving to
our country i suggest
you come here for vacation for three
four days and see how you like it
and we are given 500 tax credits if you
come here
from america come pay a visit to us and
see if you like that
if you do we would love for you to
consider to bring your talents
and your resources to our country at 300
deposits you bring to our country we
give you citizenship
and with the benefit of our citizenship
you get the following boom boom boom
boom boom
if that starts happening with another
country recruiting people away from
america and that country has something
to offer
[Laughter]
it's going to get very interesting
because you can run a business out of
any country and you're zooming in
you can have people you're running it
from all over the place you can zoom in
right i got people working for us from
armenia we got people working for us
from india we got people working for us
from
colombia we got people all over the
place because they can work remotely so
if something like that were to happen
america
could see somewhat of people being
comfortable knowing that if
you know america goes the wrong
direction have a have a second choice i
can go somewhere else would you
secretly or even not so secretly
actually
love to see that abs i wouldn't i would
i would secretly and publicly never want
to see that
ever once you do not want to see that
ever in
a billion years i would never want to
see that ever
zero not even point zero one percent
ever want to see that happen
but you know what i would love to see
happen i would love to see a country
get to a point that they have the
resources
and the offer to get others to consider
that you could leave
i'd love to have a country that's an
option two where america realizes
there is option two when there is an
option two the country can bully to say
you're not going anywhere you know what
newsome said yesterday
newsome goes out and there's a press
conference for like i don't know what it
was at the dodgers stadium i don't know
if you guys saw the story out a couple
days ago i don't
we didn't put it here put newsome best
place to do business in
america he said california is still the
best place to do business in america
people said what the hell is this guy
talking about is he smoking something
he's just tone deaf is that he says
california is the best place to do
business
in america just type in news go to
liverpool state of the state address
where's this news actually can knew some
state address generals
yeah he said there was a state of the
state anyways you have to really look
through it
and you would see best place to do
business search for it best place
you know there's another one again yeah
he said business just type in business
put the keyword business well
has the most innovation venture capital
small business in the country we will
keep fostering every smaller
certain drivers of gdp so we build uh
special taxes on that not only families
our own small businesses you know
government
covet boom there's only providing small
business
you'll find it if you keep looking for
it you'll find he says california's the
best place to do business
what does it say the special mix of
audacity human capital and creativity
founded in california means there's
literally no better place to do business
audacity is a great word it's the
audacity can you imagine
it's the audacity of sacramento to tax
and regulate businesses and he uses
you know it's our audacity to be
entrepreneurs and stuff you know
anything about
entrepreneurs you got the audacity to
tax and regulate and chase them out
i mean let's speak it and look he was
talking about we have the ability to
create the california for business and
jobs and everything
you know what he sounds like he sounds
like tennessee
right we have the ability to build this
wait you did build it you were the
golden state you were
you know california put the man on the
moon yeah you you
fumbled the opportunity we have the
opportunity to create this what's with
the vision somebody told them
hey your speech has got to have vision a
lot of vision a lot of vision you know
you have to be positive you got to be
assertive you have to show leadership
and vision
and then everything you say now is going
to you're going to get meme to death
this guy already has 1.9 recall votes
and they say 30 percent of them are from
moderate democrats and what did yahoo
say what did yahoo say about him and
florida
oh yeah that a closer inspection
california actually did
better than florida did on the covid
thing and then yahoo news picks up like
two sets of stats to put in there that
did show a reflection
but what are they really doing it's
yahoo news and liberal media
supporting their guy the guy that wears
their jersey
you know i think and trying to pick on
florida and desantis a little bit
because he wears the other jersey
i'm not sure if you understand though
tom because uh francisco in fresno he
received five thousand dollars to reopen
his pastry business
after being closed for six months i mean
he's he's sad he's good
sarcasm right guys by the way what kai
just read
newsom actually said that are you
cringing
is anybody else cringing that's why he
said it that's why it's so pathetic yeah
that's right
when i was looking at this i'm like you
got to be he said this two days ago and
i'm like oh my god like that's a case
example of how business is
trying to say what a great do you know
how many we are we are still 25 to 30
percent the state of california
i cannot tell you how yesterday i had a
call with a couple that
chris and mary had a call with them you
know the call i had the sam
we were setting up chris and mary the
zoom i was doing and i'm talking to them
they're from san diego they've been
there their entire lives they love san
diego they don't want to go anywhere
else they've never lived anywhere else
you know what she said she said i'm
worried they have they have i think
seven kids
i'm worried seven kids i said why are
you worried
because i've never lived in another
place i've never moved to another place
i don't know where to go this is all i
know it's and i said i totally
understand i said for me
it's not a big deal because i lived in
iran i lived in germany i lived in l.a i
lived in south carolina i lived in
kentucky tennessee
dallas florida i'm good because if you
push me out i'm
going to another place i love america i
fight to make sure these freedoms stay
put because i don't want to go anywhere
else i would like to stay to stay in
this great guy i served in this
country's army
i love this place right what's the point
there
call-ins but we can't stay here longer
because
california is just constantly
challenging us
constantly making it difficult the other
day i'm driving on the freeway and i see
a guy
who's changing his tire i see a chp
giving him a ticket i can't see and he's
just going through all these stories
that he's telling me here
and you got a new son going out there
telling a story about california is the
best place to do business
the reason why desantis and abbott are
winning is because of
ludicrous stupid statements being made
by a guy like that in the state of
california
okay that's why desantis and abbott are
winning on
paper with business with small business
owners
and a guy like that is being you know
destroying small businesses and is
thinking there's no way people
the pompous the arrogance no one will
leave california
nobody will leave california look we've
been around the block what happens to
arrogant people
what happens to them eventually you
can't go around walking around thinking
you're
infamous and somebody cannot not you
know you're you're so powerful that
somebody cannot touch uh knock you out
nobody is untouchable
nobody right is untouchable nobody
is untouchable nobody is untouched that
includes the city of california anyways
even elon musk is untouchable elon musk
is not untouchable this is why i brought
it up in the last podcast saying
elon musk could be the target of the
federal government and twitter because
he's becoming too powerful they don't
like one individual getting too powerful
if he becomes too powerful through you
said 37
what was the number 37 percent where are
we at here let's just go to it right 37
of uh uh am i missing the story here or
where is it at let me see okay first of
all he lost 25 billion dollars
is it page one yeah 37 americans in a
recent online survey say they've made
trades based on elon musk's tweet
that's out of 30 400 responders they
said yes we responded to his tweets and
we invested in what he did 16
said that invested many time based on
tesla ceo's tweets nearly
half of a respondent said they found
musk's market moving tweets quite
amusing in august 2018 musk
got himself in trouble with the u.s
securities and exchange commission after
tweeting
about taking tesla private said he had
funding secured recently his tweets
about gamestop
had drawn the ira bill gross who made an
ill-time bet against gamestop
engineering caused him to lose much
15 million at one point musk is a little
devil and he enjoys playing these games
growth said about him last month so
you know guys like kim got to be a
little bit careful but tom
why don't we go into the story that you
want us to go into which is a spacex
story okay
elon musk spacex now owns about a third
of all activity
active satellites in the us uh
spacex created a sporm of about a
thousand satellites that is circulating
about 340 miles overhead for some
uh early customers of 99 a month
startling service the satellites
are already moving already improving how
rural communities
access internet more startling
satellites were put in orbit last year
than had been launched by the all the
rocket providers in the world in 2019
that is
insane spacex has promised at satellite
clusters
will bring cheap high-speed internet to
the masses by beaming data to every
corner on the globe the company now says
it has roughly
10 000 customers which proves that
starlink is no longer theoretical
and experimental fiber optics-based
internet providers are
against hit and are pushing back against
the federal government's decision to
award spacex
nearly 900 million dollars in subsidies
tom
thoughts there is always a mission
behind the mission for elon musk
you know i did a case study two years
ago and i said that i thought tesla was
an energy company
and now everybody's coming guess what
you know popular
popular media and press are getting
behind that and i pointed out i said
look
the the infrastructure to charge the
tesla is going to become an industry and
it's valuable unto itself
the power wall and everything they've
done especially i mean look at high
energy cost states like hawaii
here's what i think is happening here
spacex oh he wants to send somebody to
mars oh he wants to make money
launching things for other people no
it's a communications company
just like tesla is an energy company
underneath i think spacex is a
communication company underneath he
wants to
he is passionate about education he is
passionate about communication
i think that's what's under spacex
that's what i think is going on
telecommunications that's behind the
scenes what's going on here yep
look he's he's building a network he
wants to have free education out there
for
for for the average person he's got a
big heart for the average
you know the average person living in a
rural community to have
connectivity to the internet and the
education background do that that's what
i think is going on
so he's uh here's my question to you as
a business owner this is the part that
stuck to me obviously it's ridiculous
that one-third of all satellites in
space is
2019. from elon musk like what
um here's my question to you as a
business owner it says must noted in a
tweet that the company needs to quote
unquote
pass through a deep chasm of negative
cash flow
over the next year or so to make
starlink financially viable
from a business owner what does that
mean that you need to spend money in
order to make money what's your take on
that specific sentence it's nothing new
it's that that happens to a lot of
people means i'm a startup and i'm going
to build through it that's that's not
even a it's a no-brainer he has to do
that it's a
normal concept for where he's at it's
what people had to go through with them
in tesla it's what people had to go
through with amazon and bezos it's what
people had to go through
right that's been around for a while and
here you're not betting on the company
you're betting on
elon to be able to pull this off so
explain that a little bit further when
you said oh it's a common thing and
that's why i kind of set you up for this
what does that mean exactly so when
you're starting a business you
understand that you're going to take
some deep losses you need to invest
and you're going to lose millions or
invest millions in order to come out on
the other side
three to five years later to make 10
million 100 million whatever the number
like
what's that business model how many
times have you seen one of the rockets
he launches
explode how many times have you seen it
now i've seen it a few times how many
times is it
like seriously we've seen it many times
right what's the big deal nowadays
nothing and do you know do you see how
he handles it let me get this straight
you run a company
that you know sends
rockets into space and
failing is what part of the process an
explosion
and he says ah okay all right next one
it's not like
it's the end of the world this guy's got
rockets exploding left and right and
it's just like going off to the next one
because
in his mind it's like i'm going to
figure this thing out you got to worry
about i want to figure this thing out
my only concern is
go back to a time where one individual
has had
had as much power and influence as he
does and their name wasn't
starting with a president tell me the
last time an
individual had more power and
influence more power and influence than
elon musk does today
and their name didn't start with
president tell me what was the
rockefeller john d rockefeller yeah i
disagree
i fully disagree with you guys because
you have the power of twitter
guys there is no social media with
rockefeller what are you talking about
rockefeller would write a story it took
you two weeks to read about it
he would send a tweet it took a month to
find out about it
china didn't find out about what
rockefeller said for two months how are
you gonna find out about the news
there's no way to send it to you
this guy says something boom like this
people go on
you know short trade e-trade their
website
marcus and they buy stocks and they go
on robinhood
so when we're officially at a phase
where individuals
can have more power than countries and
this guy is getting to a point right now
who has more influence right now for
people to take action
if joe biden tweets tomorrow go buy
walmart stock how many people buy it
maybe like four no everybody shorts it
yeah
yeah if elam was tomorrow if joe biden
says tomorrow hey you know what uh
here's what i think about dogecoin
you're like dude you don't know
who sent this tweet like can you we want
to know the staffer
but if but he would call it doggy coin
and he would actually call walmart
kmart so let's remember we're talking
about that's a good point but if this
guy goes out there and sends a tweet
who responds to it the entire world
stops apparently 37
of americans are making trades based on
a elon musk that concern that
we're about to find out how
how you know there was a book written
just
with all of trump's tweets it's a book
you go buy the book
it's all of his tweets in a book and it
was a bestseller it's a book
with his tweets okay and it explains the
timing of the tweets
trump was able to get world's attention
with one platform
okay now some may say this guy's taking
it to a whole different level elon musk
the kind of influence that he's having
right now because if you think about
trump's influence wasn't go by real
estate in new york
trump's influence wasn't go by this
stock that wasn't trump's influence
trump wrote a book called what art of
the deal right and they did very well
and
bestseller for many many years trump had
a tv show trump was entertaining trump
was making money trump was doing all
that stuff
but trump wasn't telling you where to go
invest your money trump wasn't go trump
played a political game he put a
one-page ad and you know president bush
going to war not the right decision and
he put that i don't know what a
newspaper was in new york times or
wall street journey he put him one of
those he he played for the longest time
he was involved in politics
this guy's influencing other industries
so we're about to learn what happens to
an individual who has this much power
and recently he comes out saying
he supports free education but not the
kind of free education of fifty thousand
dollars to
discount it he gives five million
dollars to khan academy a generous five
million dollar donation to khan academy
khan academy i think he started the
website he started his youtube channel
helping his
niece or something do homework it's a
simple story now he supports
free education but not free education
has in scholarships
free education as in you could go to a
youtube channel and take geometry
you can go to this one place and learn
about the history of this you can go to
this one place for free and learn about
coding
he is he is hurting a lot of industries
he is hurting a lot of companies he is
taking business away from a lot of
powerful people
and i'm just wondering at what point is
there going to be a meeting behind
closed doors
of all the people that he's putting to
work there's nothing
more annoying than you're somebody
that's making 10 million
every year and you've been kicking back
for 15 years golfing seven days a week
you're just chilling you go to the
restaurants mr whatever your last name
is
and then all of a sudden a guy shows up
where you have to get back to work and
you haven't worked for 20 years
people don't like people like that
behind closed doors those people are
hated i have a bit of an experience in
that myself
personally elon's taking that to a whole
different level he
is hated because he's putting a lot of
his competitors
back to work of having to show up to
office early again
because he's not stopping so what how
long will this last
i have no idea i have no idea so it
doesn't sound like you guys have an
opinion on it okay
do you think there's a simulation
between between uh reed hastings
and um elon musk in the sense that they
kind of
they disrupted big industries and
and blaze the path uh no
reid hastings is not elon musk reed
hastings is just a guy that
destroyed you know hurt and industry
where how many the grammy awards went to
netflix was it 17 i don't know what it
was the number was just ridiculous right
and
where a uh gervais what's his name ricky
gervais he goes up and says
you know forget about who are you guys
you guys are nobody everybody's calling
netflix and he said if
the uh uh what did he say if the isis
was to come out with a new streaming
service you would be calling your agent
to say get me on that streaming service
to get a contract with them right
meaning you're selling your
soul to anybody so no what netflix did
is one industry
he's not doing one industry he is not
touching one industry
he's touching 5 10 15 20 industries
he is going to collectively piss off a
lot of people
and those people that he pisses off
their expertise is to have paid off a
politician in the back
where no one knows about and those
politicians own
oh those people a lot of favors and i
don't know what's going to happen there
honestly i don't know what angle they're
going to take with them what's really
interesting you bring up something very
interesting i think we have to peel it
back a little bit and take a look both
spacex and tesla have something in
common they have federal subsidies on
their
on their products and so you got the 500
million
correct spacex that's right spacex
billion dollars isn't a big number from
the government but that's
very very real and so the um the rural
education play and
and the uh satellite play for rural
internet it's got a billion dollars of
subsidies
meanwhile you got these guys time warner
and people like that verizon putting
fiber
optics in the ground or getting really
pissed off by that and
as we all know there's still you know um
what fifteen thousand dollars of federal
subsidies in every electric vehicle
so you know when you add up the battery
and all the parts and everything that
goes in and actually the end price
and so there's you know there's a lot of
government that is lined up in the u.s
with elon and so the question is
does the lobbying go the other way and
have it shift and that's what i look for
i look for when does elon start to lose
the support of the government in the
form of these subsidies because he's got
some friends somewhere
um and they're helping somewhere elon
they're given subsidies from the
government somebody's
somebody's been part of a meeting that
says hey you know what here you go
you know who are the scariest people
i've ever competed against you know you
know what people i actually fear when it
comes down to competition
people who have uh the regulated people
who have connections
no i'm gonna tell you the scariest
people you'll ever face
in your lifetime that could ruin you not
willing to do whatever they can to hurt
you
is lazy ambitious people yeah yeah
lazy ambitious people are the most
dangerous people you'll ever go up
against
because they're lazy but they're
ambitious they're not willing to do the
work that you're doing to get the
success you're getting
but they still have your level of
ambition if not higher lazy ambitious
people are great manipulators and game
players
phenomenal added so meaning what
how many people does elon face today who
are lazy ambitious people who were at
one point somebody 20 30 years ago or 15
years ago
who are now ambitious still but very
very lazy how many
you have described most of the auto
industry i just described most of the
auto industry i just described most of
politicians i just described most of the
people that are in the financial
industry i just described
a lot of people who made their money
they just don't want to get to work
his number one enemy is not the sec
it's lazy ambitious people the lazy
ambitious people are who are the ones
that are going to make his life a living
kill you know what's the crazy thing
about lazy ambitious people
you rarely know they start it but they
know and say oh he did it
that's the secret sauce of lazy
ambitious people i don't know if that
made sense or not
so they go behind closed doors and they
know how to do
did you hear about what that person said
about you oh look i got
i mean let me tell you what i did i
defended you i got a call from a guy
saying hey
the other day was this place and they
said this about you but let me i said
i said first of all why are they so
comfortable to talk smack about me in
front of you the whole line that jase
uses in his song why are they so
comfortable to talk smack about me in
front of you
maybe you gave them that comfort that
they can talk smack about me in front of
you so maybe you join the club
of let me have them trash our buddy here
so the lazy ambitious people behind
closed doors
they know how to put the thing together
and they said you know what he said
about you
and they're like oh i did it
responsibilities off them so they still
they close allies and they put it on him
but they started the whole thing
he's giving birth to a lot of people
like that and
uh because okay do you think they're
gonna let this guy be worth a trillion
dollars in the next five years
do you think the to the point where he
says this
okay you don't want to give me the
subsidies of 900 million i don't care i
got 900 million don't give me the
subsidies
i'm worth a trillion dollars then all of
a sudden they're going to say oh [ __ ] he
no longer needs us you know what
boom lock him in people like elon musk
typically the lazy ambitious people get
very scared of people like ilan
because ilan doesn't know how to what
how to stop
he's not going to stop he's not trying
to be a billionaire to live in a big ass
house
that comes with it he's not trying to go
date all the hot girls he's already had
a plenty everybody wants to find out
what this guy's like
he's uh he's not trying to go have
dinner with the cool people he's done it
so many times
he wants to change the world world
changers scare the hell out of lazy
ambitious people
there's not that many people at this
level they're they're some of the most
this remember how the same way i said
lazy ambitious people are the people
you fear because they know how to behind
closers ruin the game
you know who lazy ambitious people fear
the most ten times more
hardworking ambitious people they're
frightened and envious of illama's type
of people
envious because you have that moxie that
they go to sleep every night saying i
actually think this guy's going to pull
it off and what if he pulls it off and
everybody's going to realize that i was
wrong and i'm going to lose face and i'm
going to do this i can't let that happen
let me see what i'm going to do they go
to sleep all night long to try to stop
that person
[Music]
world guess who the world favors by the
way the world
favors guess who history favors
the you're saying not the most history
favors the bold baby
history history favors the bold that's
elon musk
history favors the bowl that's why we
keep giving birth
to new elon musk so dude more power to
you
go do it just i hope he doesn't get a
little out of control
where he creates enemies that he doesn't
need to create you're going to create
enemies just don't create the enemies
that are unnecessary enemies to create
speaking of birth of
elon musk do you know how many kids he
has five
you knew that yeah okay do you know the
the the breakdown of the kids the thing
with the first one was four
uh uh was it huh
yeah here's a little fun fact you said
berth he's got
now he has six kids now okay he had he
lost his first kid i believe was his
first never wants to talk about it
yeah he had he has two twin boys yep
then he had
triplets so five boys and now he has a
six boy with the musician
grimes that he named the kid uh some
a-x-a-e whatever but do you know one of
the triplets names
the youngest triplet or the youngest
triple nicola what is it
kai that's cool kai did you know that
maybe he's been planted here to support
anyway i thought that was very
interesting
all boys uh twins
triplets and now a kid from outer space
i like what you just did it's like when
i talk to tikkon dylan sometimes i'm
like guys let me tell you about the
history of what happened here
dad do you know in minecraft how many
different
things you can build we just gotta we
just went to a different direction so
what you you're not worried about it
sounds like you because you think
everything's gonna be okay with iran no
one's gonna bother them the lazy
ambitious army is not gonna unite and go
out no i
look there's a reason here why we've got
you know 10 pages of stories whatever
and
four of the pages about elon fricken
musk the guy's a financial rock star and
he's
otherworldly and even his newborn baby
is named after a
solar system or something how much money
do you need to live comfortably in every
state in america today you want to pull
up the story the median necessary living
wage across the country right now 67
690 however here are the top three
states
and the bottom three states the bottom
three states which one are you going to
the top three
the most expensive states to live in in
america top three can you guess who it
is i'm curious enough they can guess can
you guess what is the most expensive
state to live in in america kai i want
you to give a tweet on the last one
before we wrap up that's what we're
going to do with questions
not right now while i do this we'll go
to it can you take a while guess what's
the most expensive
state to live in in america do you guys
know what it is most expensive
you want to take a wild guess what's
tickle wild guess what is the most
expensive country to live in america
center
state does hawaii count okay hawaii is
number one
you're right why would hawaii not count
hawaii is one okay can you go a little
lower kai so we can see it as
international go a little lower
hawaii is hawaii is number one well then
i'll just say it hawaii is number one
then it's california you need 136 000 a
year to live in hawaii
okay median okay you need
99 971 to have a average
decent lifestyle in california you need
95 000
in new york you want the bottom three
here we go mississippi
is at the bottom you need 58 58 000
you're going to be getting the vip
section at applebee's and have an
incredible
incredible clam chowder soup don't try
the chicken breast
then after that is arkansas place i've
been i've been to arkansas it's right
next door to us
we've been there i've had a good time
with my friends in arkansas third
lowest is bama
alabama roll tide that's it roll tide
yeah that's right nick saban
alabama is third that's what it takes in
america
hawaii one when we were in hawaii
how many people kept coming to us saying
thank you so much for doing your trip
here
thank you so much for doing it you're so
happy bringing commerce tips
was unbelievable how grateful they were
because homelessness in hawaii took a
massive hit
it wasn't a pretty excited in hawaii uh
on what happened there
so it was exciting seeing there but
again folks if you're thinking about
going to hawaii make sure you're making
over 136 thousand dollars before you
make that move
because you need 136 to live
in hawaii before we wrap up if you're
going to say yeah
we're not knocking hawaii and there's
two reasons for we are not going to
watch
this it's just two simple reasons for it
the quick energy is very expensive to
make there and it costs you a lot for
energy number one
and number two shipping cost everything
is shipped to hawaii so you're not
getting screwed in hawaii on pricing
it's just the cost of bringing milk food
all kinds of things to hawaii
is huge so you're paying for shipping
costs to get all that stuff to hawaii so
you can enjoy the island and then
making energy on the islands is very
expensive and that's the two reasons
when you add up those two things
that makes hawaii very expensive i think
this is also a good
uh kind of goes to show that raising a
minimum wage a flat minimum wage doesn't
make sense because
it's quite different uh medium incomes
that you need to to live
in hawaii versus alabama or mississippi
very good point
how are they defining live comfortably
because that's what this whole premise
on this is the money
money you need to live comfortably do
they define what living comfortably
means
well maybe it's not at your level you
know like you know yeah i know you have
a
bone in ribeye every night and you know
they're talking about
normal people here by the way for just
so everybody knows i
love hawaii and we just took 450 people
to hawaii they treat us
royally when we go to hawaii uh let's do
a shout out shout out to the people
that are doing a song the people that
are working in kaplan
and lahaina and especially the staff of
the hyatt regency
in maui we do a shout out for them they
were just so hospitable
so pleasing so glad for us to be there
and you know our guys you know tipped
him out took care of him give him a lot
of encouragement
and just uh thank you to that whole side
of maui
that entertained us agree last story
here takai did you come up with anything
or no any tweets that you want to bring
up
if not i'm going to go into the china
story last story
china is behind a huge cyber attack of
microsoft microsoft is in the middle of
a cyber attack
cyber crisis right now hackers targeted
weaknesses in microsoft exchange service
which is used by small and medium-sized
companies
the attack allowed hackers to access the
email accounts of at least 30 000
organizations in the us and has affected
hundreds of thousands of microsoft
customers around the world
microsoft flat out said the hack came
from a group tied to the chinese
government called
hafnium the biden administration is
launching an emergency task force to
address this aggressive cyber attack the
second major hacking
campaign to hit the u.s since the
election as this comes on the heels of
solar winds a separate series of
sophisticated attacks
attributed to russia that breached about
a hundred u.s companies and nine federal
agencies tom
thoughts um we're living in a cold war
now
and it's being fought in digital pipes
it's as simple as that and china and
russia are trying to assert themselves
as the new duopoly of world power
and they're going after things that
matter and so if anybody doesn't think
that we're in a cold war right now
they're not paying attention we may not
be putting pushing missiles in germany
to take down the berlin wall and things
like that
but we are in the middle of a cold war
and people need to pay attention to it
yeah we brought it up in the last
podcast that uh you know i think it was
with den
with danielle dimartino booth and i said
look we've been talking about china we
talking about china
at what point are we like is like the
alarm bells are going to go off
you know trump kind of signaled some of
the alarms with the trade war but that
was more about soybeans than
actual intellectual property but the ccp
you know they are they are enemy number
one and i've
we've addressed it and i've kind of just
hitting this home and hitting this home
there this is enemy number one and uh
we talked about it last time that the
problem in america right now is that
we're fighting amongst ourselves
and we have to um rectify that come to
terms with that and start fighting
against
who our real enemy is which is china
coming after our
everything we got so yesterday i talked
to the former director of cia
james woolsey i had him on okay big name
back in the day
big name back in the days he was hired
by bill clinton he was a director of ci
if you remember
the the the the one individual that we
had was a former cia agent of 31 years
that turned against us and
the espionage and what was the last name
amid or
uh i can't think of his last name and uh
he turned against the u.s
and he was a director of ci when that
even took place okay back in 1994 i want
to say
february when when that came out and it
led to james was right there aldrick
ames
is who was a former ci agent that ended
up becoming a kgb
um spy and helped out for them and
shared a lot of intel with them right so
we talked about different countries and
he brought up uh china
and he brought up russia and we brought
up you know a bunch of different things
that we're talking about
i said what's your biggest concern and
threat that we have right now
on how they can attack us give me a
creative way
he said the electromagnetic pulse
emp right it was the first time this was
ever brought up in a
debate was by newt gingrich when in 2011
2012 in a presidential debate they asked
what is the biggest threat that we
should worry about
he said emp electromagnetic pulse and
everybody's like uh
let me go to google what the hell is an
amp right so
look um you know you notice two stories
russia targets what twitter china
targets who
microsoft microsoft okay and uh
what is the real long-term ramifications
control threat if somebody decides to
because what an
emp is they drop it a mile above you
and it it kind of explodes but it's not
a bomb it's not anything
and all of a sudden it takes out all
your electric
powers all the plants go ahead remember
ocean's 11. yeah exactly that's a very
small glimpse of it yeah where don
cheadle's up there with that big ol
yup big battery and he covers up his uh
manhood and presses the button
that's an emp it takes out all the
electricity in the entire town of las
vegas so this can take it out
in the entire country if they wanted to
right emp so
you remember how i said um you know what
can russia really do to twitter
if they really wanted to some of these
empires they're not held accountable to
u.s
it's not like their accountability is to
them what can they do and who can they
blame
you pull them over give them the ticket
so no cops on your nationals
i think things are getting very
interesting i think things are getting
very very interesting and by the way
none of this stuff is new
none of it is new on what's going on but
uh is it about to get to a level where
you know some some crazy stuff is going
to happen were we're going to get a real
real experience of what it is because
what happens if we lose electricity for
a month
imagine you have no power then what
happens chaos what kind of chaos
how long can it last how long is it
sustainable
how long can the generators last what
happens once the generators are gone
what happens to the people that don't
have generators
who do they go to what happens to the
people that have generators do they keep
it a secret what happens
how long before we recover from it how
long before we come back up from it it's
very very interesting
uh on what's happening today and what
i'm trying to say to the listeners i'm
very optimistic about it yeah your
future looks very very bright
future looks very bright but we're
hoping that people
will play nice and they'll find a way to
be diplomatic amongst this amongst each
other
and somehow someway realize that at the
end of the day if you do something to
another person it can backfire in
another way and i'm hoping that's the
one part that gets people
to not go to the craziest routes of
doing dumb things small things like
microsoft twitter maybe that can happen
i just hope it's not the level of
retaliation with the retaliation keeps
getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger so
anyways it'll be interesting to see what
happens here with
uh uh microsoft and twitter look i've
really enjoyed today's uh podcast
uh we started at 8 30. we're going to
test it next week to see if we start at
nine o'clock what that looks like
i have a zoom i got to jump on myself we
all got things we got to do but for
those of you guys that were with us
from the beginning to the end much love
to you if you enjoyed tom being on with
us today
let him know both on twitter and let us
know
by smashing that subscribe
button take care everybody bye bye bye
bye
bye shout out to the biz doc being on
the show
you